[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine ganz einfache
sommerliche torte ich werde mit zitronen
mond worte mit himbeer machen
nein ich nenne sie hubert orte mit
zitrone und worden denn der himmel
sollen schon im vordergrund stellen ja
dafür brauche ich jetzt erst mal einen
richtig leckeren kuchen
dafür verwende ich 200 gramm butter 160
gramm zucker eine prise salz etwas
vanille extrakt die eier diese zimmer
waren 320 gramm mehl eineinhalb
teelöffel backpulver etwas
zitronenschale und saft 40 kommunen und
200 gramm butter milch dies auch schon
etwas erwärmt das nimmt ihr einfach die
weiche butter die da wirklich richtig
weich sein honig so lässt sie sich am
besten aufschlagen
und dann kommt sie in die rührschüssel
da kommen zur pause setzte bisschen
vanille extrakt und dann könnt ihr die
zutaten so für etwa vier bis fünf
minuten schön cremig verrühren
es ist die macher schön weiß cremig so
sollte sie aussehen also richtig schön
geschmeidig mit ist wichtig dass die
eier wirklich zimmer war mit dem die
masse eben nicht gerinnt und jetzt
wieder so schön sagen würde
1 1 nach den anderen setzen würden das
heißt ein einrühren
das ist komplett verbunden ist und dann
erst das nächste wir sehen
der elegante
[Musik]
richtig schön
ich kann jetzt das mehl mit backpulver
mischen die zutaten kommen jetzt hier
rein
das mehl übrigens vorher unbedingt nicht
jeden
ich habe mit seinen extra feines mail
deswegen haben sie nicht nur sie jetzt
eine prise zitronen abrieb nicht so viel
soll dennoch ganz leicht nach zitrone
schmecken kopf muss oben
den rest habe ich aber ab denn den 61
[Musik]
guckt mal so viel zu tun haben und die
kann ich jetzt einfach in ein kleines
gefäß geben von 14 jetzt noch etwas
zitronensaft
[Musik]
und die zitronenschale könnt ihr dann
nach dem kompletten auspressen einfach
als spülmaschinen endlich spielen
ergeben dann ist alles verwertet und
dann nahm sie es auch wirklich bio
zitrone zu kaufen und unbehandelte jetzt
kommt hier noch der monatslohn
kommen die buttermilch kriegst du augen
nahaufnahme okay
und jetzt wirklich nur noch ganz ganz
kurz berühren nicht zu lange
[Musik]
ich finde ich weiß ohne daraus sobald
modem teil wird ich finde es einfach
schön und jung sprechen was man auf
englisch heißt der englische name ist so
süß ich würde am liebsten ist öfter
morgen benutzen hobbys oder sondern
sollten sowohl im englischen sagt ich
glaube ich sage ab sofort immer beziehen
jetzt ist der wunderschöne teig fertig
und wird hier aufgeteilt ich habe hier
zwei bringe bereits auf 20 cm
durchmesser eingestellt und ich nehm 2
weil sich dann die backzeit verknüpft
und die passen eben auch wunderbar zu
zweit auf ein blech schön aufteilen und
einfach verstreichen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der teig direkt im
backofen wird gebacken und ich warte
einfach drauf bis er fertig ist und
abgekühlt ist bis es dann gleich weiter
geht
[Musik]
der kuchen ist es gebacken und abgekühlt
und ich ziehen jetzt direkt hier vom
blech herunter auf eine abkühlung
löst den rahmen jetzt hier mit einem bug
vorn mensa der kühl ist auch schneller
ab weil es eben zwei backen verwendet
hat 30 kuchen einfach dünn und ist
insgesamt einfach schneller fertig
[Musik]
debug folie könnte jetzt ganz einfach
drunter weg ziehen in dem umschlag und
einfach darum wegrollt da geht der
kuchen nicht kaputt und viel schneller
ab
[Musik]
jetzt noch mit einem sauberen geschäft
abdecken komplett abkühlen lassen und
dann stelle ich ihnen sogar noch mal
kurz in den kühlschrank und kann mich in
der zwischenzeit schon mal um die krim
kümmern
jetzt sind die beiden bilden komplett
abgekühlt und es geht direkt an die
creme da mache ich jetzt eine
zitronencreme wenn es eher weniger zu
drohen ich haben möchte dann lasst die
zitrone einfach weg und macht einfach
nur mal electric zum beispiel heraus
also ich benutze jetzt wieder eine
zitrone die ist unbehandelt das heißt
ich kann die schale mit verwerten
80 gramm puderzucker 400 gramm quark 400
gramm schlagsahne etwas vanille extrakt
und seiner fahrt zum steif schlagen
ich habe ich noch etwas mond für die
dekoration und in bern für die füllung
und natürlich für obendrauf
ja das tue ich jetzt zuerst ich nehme
erst mal die zitrone
wie gesagt ich mag selbst betone ich das
heißt bei mir kommt jetzt hier die ganze
schale mit rein
könntet ihr natürlich sagen man hat ja
auch die schale von vorhin benutzen
können ja aber ich nehme jetzt hier noch
mal die ganze und auch den saft der
ganzen zitrone
daher brauche ich jetzt den komplett auf
[Musik]
was ich ganz so zitrone mond hinkam
passend schon mal optisch so zu sagen
dass man die zitrone ist sehr groß ist
nimmt nur die hälfte
ich nehme jetzt aber die ganze nicht so
aber so ein bisschen was ist übrig das
nimmt gleich irgendein wasser gebe ich
nicht den quark dazu
damit bruder zucker ryan miller extrakte
kurz berühren
[Musik]
jetzt kurz verrühren bis jetzt langsam
die sahne dazu
ich mache es kurz aus denn ich habe so
eine bio sahne und dies immer nicht ganz
so homogen das heißt der rahmen setzt
sich gern mal ab und hier solltet ihr
darauf achten schlagsahne muss immer
eiskalt sein
ich dachte mir ich muss nicht erwähnen
aber seitdem ich stamme und seine
schlagsahne abenteuer kenne weiß ich
dass ich sagen muss schlagsahne muss
immer eiskalt sein am besten die
rührschüssel kalt der schneebesen kalt
und dann kann eigentlich nichts schief
gehen ihr dürft halt nicht zu lange
rühren wenn ihr nämlich zu lange geführt
dann setzt sich die sahne in butter und
rahm als eben das ganz flüssige und das
war halt nicht ganz so gut
und wenn es zu warm ist lässt sie sich
gar nicht erst statt schlagen und wird
dann sofort gründlich und flüssig und
dann mit seiner partei schlagen
[Musik]
trapani sahne schlagen mit der
küchenmaschine wirklich darauf achten
nicht so lange wie wir mal kurz vorher
aufhören coco ob sie schon steif ist die
brauchen noch ein paar umdrehungen
die
da kann es schnell passieren so gibt es
zwei mal zu viel und dann ist dieser
überschlagen
das kann ich die torte direkt auf der
tortenplatte anrichten und ich nehme
dann einfach den toten drehteller aber
ich soeben einfach arbeiten kann man so
eine antirutschmatten dann kann auch
nichts verrutschen so beide böden sind
gleichmäßig deswegen ist es eigentlich
egal welche uns in welcher oben ist
[Musik]
ein konkretes die hälfte oder creme
drauf noch gar nicht probiert aber ich
denke sie ist gut
das wird so ein naked kate habe ich
musste immer betonen die torte ist nicht
der mensch und das heißt nicht dass
nackte torte nicht nackt das backen
könnt ihr auch machen aber damit will
ich nichts zu tun
ja ein kinderkanal sind wir hier kinder
und familien
ach guck mal das muss gar nicht
gleichmäßig aussehen so bietet so ein
bisschen dirty arbeit muss ich sagen
aber dann ist das was ich vorher gesagt
habe okay ich sage einfach gar nichts
mehr
jetzt ein bisschen mohn darauf streuen
jetzt noch sagt dass man auf türkisch
fascies dann springt setzt okay okay
und jetzt kommen hier noch in bern rein
[Musik]
für innen reicht mir das anhören denn
der boden drauf erinnert mich
tatsächlich an meinen victorias cache
aber den habe ich noch nicht nicht
verfilmt der ist sein buch backen für
jeden anlass und den hab ich damals für
vox gemacht für als ich in
großbritannien war und habe da praktisch
so eine britische team gemacht für
sabine und dann habe ich den victoria zu
spät gemacht als richtig britischen
kuchen für die sahne jetzt auch schön
firmensoftware sonderbonus
ist ja gerade jetzt auch ein bisschen
montag in bern drauf und dann ab in die
kühlung denn der muss jetzt wirklich gut
durch kühlen bevor wir durchschneiden
können und dann wird er gleich
[Musik]
ich glaube dass jetzt aber gleich noch
machen ist denn es ist ja auch eine
zitrone und orte also brauche ich hier
nach
das habe ich es um testen reißer
inspector gadget ihr wird und kann es
hier schön die zitronenschale
neben und noch nicht aufgeben
[Musik]
tragt ihr so schöne kleine zitronen
löschen
[Musik]
fertig super einfach ganz schnell und
bestimmt mega lecker aber wie gesagt
erst mal kühl
[Musik]
dieses ausnahme ist die hölle los ist
publiziert wie der deb nun heißt doch
dass mond auf englisch nein hobbys
hobbys ne monats amon auf deutsch wird
sich alles komisch auch wirklich so
rasch wie sieht das ist so ich weiß
nicht aber irgendwie muss ich sagen katy
perry denken zu pop ist also wer das
chanson turnier
[Musik]
wir schreiben den sommer ganz so einfach
und so sommerlich
ich hoffe es nicht trocken ich würde
ihnen dann meine farbe
das wird durch ziehen lassen dies passt
perfekt ja ich bin passiert das ja
darauf muss verschoben werden ich bin
jetzt nicht davon ausgehen dass du alt
genügt der frauen sind seine ich wollte
es im garten der stille jahren himbeere
leider also die wand aus dem garten für
die kinder und ich gehen und viele haben
wir nicht die creme ist gut zu einer
zitronencreme läuft jetzt hat sich gerne
noch mehr werden so drauf gepackt das
über jedem bis zum hinderer hast aber
die kann jedoch dazu reichen weil die
torte haben sich ja irgendwie stark
genug betonen werden
und das freut mich
muss ich da oben vor der kamera zu ist
eigentlich jeder worum ich mich umdrehte
h oder soll ich dir ja weil ich einfach
die angebot habe ich erst lernen vor der
kamera ich mag das auch nicht mal würde
ich die ersten mal habe ich so gegessen
ja und da hab ich gesehen und dachte es
nie wieder nach genau und ich habe mich
dann auch entweder weggedreht oder so
kamera kurz runter und dann haben egal
jedenfalls kennt sie die torte gerne
ausprobieren
das rezept ist zu machen auf der leeze -
blog de oder als kostenlose apps kommt
nur alle video ist in deinem mund
aufmacht und ich glaube auch die die
größe der trotte passt weil ich so klein
und schnuckelig machten sich zum dünnes
stück ab und dafür ist es schön hoch wie
man dünnen interpretiert das stück viel
spaß machen
ich machte trotz meinte papa
hoffentlich sind
[Musik]
gg